après la guerre celui qui parle la
langue de sa région risquent la punition
quand je parlais breton faisait hier
conjuguer le verbe dactylographié à tous
les temps et à tous les modes
il en va de l'unité de la nation c'est
très sérieux et c'est même précisé dans
l'article 2 de la constitution la langue
de la république est le français que
j'attaque kg sciages que tu
dactylographe iasc qu'il claque
telegraph ya en bretagne la résistance
s'organise petit à petit pour raviver
une langue menacée d'extinction
l'outil premier il est militant il date
de 1979
ce sont les écoles diwan en 1981 il en
existe 12 dans ces écoles gratuites tous
les cours sont dispensés en breton elles
ont un statut associatif elles seront
reconnus plus tard par l etat
la langue bretonne est très riche et
certainement très enrichissant pour un
enfant d'être bilingue il faut attendre
1982 pour que l'éducation nationale se
met aux langues régionales avec la
création de classes bilingues
quelques années plus tard le parler
breton et non seulement réhabilités
mais aussi demandé par les élèves faudra
bien apprendre le breton est une langue
qui est vachement perdu et c'est dommage
je t'ai appris à l'école mais mes
parents la parle aussi d'un petit à
petit on s'est remis à parler un breton
à la maison en 1997 constat en demi
teinte pour le chanteur et défenseur de
la culture bretonne
gilles servat pour parce que on enseigne
le breton dans quelques classes
bilingues que tout va bien et agro
s'inquiéter mais c'est moins pire que
j'aurais cru qu en dehors des écoles et
de la culture
le breton a du mal à prendre plus de
place pourtant sauvegarder et promouvoir
les langues régionales
c'est une volonté de l'union européenne
elle a créé une charte pour cela la
france la signe en 1999 mais ne l'a
jamais ratifié la raison toujours la
même
l'article 2 de la constitution la langue
de la république est le français et à
tous les moyens
développer raisonnablement
l'usagé des langues régionales pour ceux
qui le souhaitent
pour le reste il faut éviter de recréer
des identités factices pour une partie
de la classe politique
la langue est plus qu'un élément
culturel c'est un outil de
revendications régionalistes ou
nationalistes à l'encontre de l'unité de
la nation
aujourd'hui la langue bretonne est parlé
par 250 milles locuteurs ce qui en fait
selon l'unesco une langue en sérieux
danger d'extinction
[Musique]